Brasil en medio de la conmoción tras el
violento ataque del congreso del palacio
presidencial de plan alto y del tribunal
Federal por Seguidores del expresidente
Jair bolsonaro que no reconocen la
victoria de Lula todo el mundo se
pregunta cómo pudieron unos pocos miles
de personas desarmadas invadiertan
fácilmente los lugares más importantes y
mejor guardados de la democracia en el
país y cómo pudieron permanecer dentro
de estos edificios durante varias horas
sin ser detenidos para el presidente
Lula da Silva la implicación de la
policía y los militares no está en duda
es importante decir que hubo muchos
Cómplices entre la Policía Militar hubo
muchas personas de las fuerzas armadas
que fueron Cómplices estoy convencido de
que la puerta del palacio se abrió para
permitir la entrada de estas personas
porque no vi que la puerta estuviera
rota es decir significa que alguien
facilitó su entrada vamos a investigar a
ver qué ha pasado
de verdad
la responsabilidad de los hechos podría
ser difícil de establecer ya que la
estructura policial brasileña es
compleja la policía federal recibe
órdenes del gobierno nacional mientras
que la Policía Militar encargada de
mantener el orden público está bajo el
mando de los gobernadores de los 27
estados de la Federación es esta última
y en particular la Policía Militar del
Distrito Federal de Brasilia la que está
ahora en el centro de las críticas está
entidad conocía los riesgos de una
invasión pocas horas antes del asalto
mientras miles de bolsonaristas
convergían hacia la capital la agencia
Nacional de inteligencia le había
transmitido boletines de alerta